louis aucoin stratèges en communication
et gestion de crise et notre rubrique
but de l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir lieu
au coin merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france ce soir pourquoi ces
craintes des autorités est ce qu'il ya
vraiment un risque finalement que ce
couple vivent aux crochets des canadiens
ben oui un bail au real risque
effectivement c'est un coup que le royal
qui a pris ses vacances
vous savez en colombie-britannique donc
qu'une affection pour le canada même si
megan est originaire des états unis donc
il ya cette question là est la question
se pose de différentes façons c'est
assez intéressant de loin
comment au québec par exemple monsieur
yves françois blanchet qui représente un
parti indépendantiste nous dit vous
savez on peut accueillir n'importe qui
dans la mesure où on n'aura pas à payer
donc ça c'est une chose au canada on dit
vous n'êtes pas les bienvenus parce que
vous représentez sa majesté et on a déjà
un système pour représenter sa majesté
ça s'appelle le gouverneur général donc
si on reçoit au canada un représentant
de la famille royale par définition ça
devrait cette personne-là qui devient le
représentant de la reine
donc ça pose un problème constitutionnel
alors c'est pas aussi simple que
simplement dire on prend un appartement
à montréal à toronto à vancouver
et puis on s'installe donc ça soulève
des vraies questions et je pense que ça
dépasse de loin la question des quelques
millions de dollars qui seront
nécessaires à assurer leur sécurité
alors justement comment ces partis parce
que ce couple normalement veut prendre
son indépendance donc n'a pas vocation à
représenter comme vous dites
la famille royale qu'est ce qui se dit
au canada justement il y aurait un peu
confusion sur ces deux statuts si j'ose
dire
mais il ya beaucoup de choses qui se
disent d'abord vous savez cette histoire
là donc c'est le jeune couple qui tente
de s'affranchir
c'est une première une histoire à
laquelle on peut se référer vous savez
comme personne comme personne du public
en général donc une première chose la
manière dont ce couple là fonctionnent
ensemble le fait que ce soit des
milléniaux donc qui ont des privilèges
mac à petit qu'ils acceptent pas
nécessairement toutes les
responsabilités qui viennent avec etc
ça fait référence à plusieurs clichés
qui sont qui sont dans l'avenir est dans
le public comme ça quand ils sont très
connus
il faut voir que au canada la monarchie
elle est omniprésente on s'enfonce
encore peut-être pas toujours compte
peut-être pas quand on visite vous savez
comme sens comme touristes mais quand on
vit ici on nous parle des procureurs de
la couronne dans les procès criminels
quand vous êtes dans un procès criminel
vous assistez à un procès de la reine
contre un de ses sujets donc c'est tout
si c'est comme ça
il les entreprises signent des contrats
avec le gouvernement mais on signe qu'on
fait avec sa majesté
les navires de la marine ce sont les
navire canadien de sa majesté donc c'est
partout en tout temps et demain vous
parle même pas de la monnaie
donc les la monarchie elle est un peu
partout mais elle ne représente pas la
même chose que vous soyez au québec chez
les francophones où que vous soyez au
canada ce sont deux mais oui parce qu'au
canada la monarchie c'est ce qui nous
distingue le plus je dirais des états
unis il ya d'autres il ya d'autres
distinctions sociales si vous voulez
mais sur le plan culturel
l'un la différence et le système du pays
donc qui distingue les canadiens anglais
des américains
alors qu'au québec c'était tout un autre
monde la distinction et les multiples et
la monarchie est fait pour partie des ce
dont on a besoin pour se distinguer du
reste de l'amérique du nord
vous voyez on a un rapport identitaire
totalement différent à la monarchie et
en plus la monarchie représente le
conquérant du québec vous savez de la
nouvelle france donc il ya une relation
amour-haine avec cette monarchie
britannique
alors ce ne sont pas plutôt les
détracteurs justement la lumière de ce
que vous nous dites du pouvoir royal qui
sont aujourd'hui les les plus critiques
envers cette venue temps mais
certainement que les détracteurs de la
monarchie viennent de trouver l'un vous
savez une espèce de deux raisons
supplémentaires de mettre en doute
l'utilité de la monarchie est
effectivement sur le plan simplement
utilitariste fonctionnelle la monarchie
soyons honnêtes on n'en a pas besoin
mais par contre sur le plan identitaire
sur le plan des symboles la monarchie
elle est au coeur du canada
donc ce qu'on dit si une partie du débat
c'est de dire vous savez la monarchie
ont l'acceptent mais on accepte à
l'étranger alors c'est l'entente qu'on a
avec la couronne britannique et c'est
l'entente qui doit être préservé mais il
n'y a pas seulement les antimonarchistes
quand même les monarchistes aussi qui
attendent avec un immense espoir
des membres de la famille royale chez
nous qui pour u serait pour les
monarchistes gens n'aiment pas beaucoup
mais y en a quand même qui se serait
comme une forme de reconnaissance de
l'importance de leur pays au sein du
commonwealth au sein de la famille
royale
alors c'est pas une opinion qui est
partagé par la majorité mais il faut
dire que elle existe merci louis aucoin
en tout cas certainement communication
et gestion de crise d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france